les employés div V d'ination jeunesse
ont désormais un président menacé de
fermeture fin octobre car l'association
n'avait plus de direction les membres du
bureau peuvent dorénavant respirer nommé
le 14 novembre dernier c'est François
Xavier béami adjoint au maire de
Versailles qui occupera la présidence
d'yij dans les prochains mois malgré un
financement assuré par les collectivités
yeline Information Jeunesse s'était
retrouvé sans tête dirigeante et dans un
vide juridique quant à la gestion de sa
situation nous avons été obligés de
constaté qu'il était très difficile de
de trouver un nouveau bureau dans cette
situation très instable et donc j'ai
proposé pour pouvoir sauver
l'association de porter ma ma
candidature à la Présidence de
l'Association de façon temporaire pour
pouvoir assurer sa sa pérenité refonder
un projet apaiser la situation
stabiliser aussi toute l'équipe et puis
repartir sur de bonnes bases ce dont je
je peux me porter garant dès aujourd'hui
c'est que dans dans les dans les dans
les mois à venir la le financement de
l'association n'est pas remis en
question
et donc la composition de l'équipe ne l'
pas non plus même si les SEP salariés du
bureau ont retrouvé un peu de sérénité
la situation reste cependant provisoire
on aurait pu être abandonné on le on le
on le pressentait et ces énergies cet
engagement de Monsieur Belami notamment
nous a redonné confiance bien sûr sur
sur la suite et sur 2014 en particulier
il y a énormément de projets et donc il
fallait que les perspectives soi soi
vraiment assuré pour pour la
on est confiant maintenant encore une
fois on reste toujours un peu en alerte
puisque on a un bureau provisoire
l'assemblée générale de l'association
prévu initialement au prier semestre
2013 devrait enfin avoir lieu le 11
décembre prochain une direction plus
pérenne pourrait t
découler